Speaker 1: in a scene completely beyond parody,
beyond satire and also a horrifying scene.
I mean, it's both.
A group of white supremacists staged a bizarre
rally in Washington, D.C., over the weekend.
They wore masks as part of their outfits.
Or maybe we maybe were supposed to call them
uniforms.
I don't know.
Outfits is a little bit emasculating.
And thanks to some kind of issue with U-Haul
rental trucks, if you can believe it, some
of them ended up being like stranded in Washington,
D.C. for hours, just based on poor planning.
Now, of course, for me, the real story here
is once again, look at how this group of protesters
Speaker 2: is treated by law
Speaker 1: enforcement and others compared
to so many others at protests around the country.
But we're going to get
Speaker 2: to that in a moment.
Speaker 1: The story is that about a hundred
members of what is now called the Patriot
Front.
If that name doesn't ring a bell, I'll explain
that as well in a moment.
A hundred members of the Patriot Front Group
rallied in Washington, DC near the White House
over the weekend.
Now, Patriot Front used to be known as Vanguard
America, but they changed their name.
Why did they change their name?
Well, because someone affiliated with Vanguard
America murdered a woman in that infamous
Unite the Right rally in Charlottesville,
Virginia.
So Vanguard America was tainted.
Now they are Patriot Front, OK?
They were there chanting that they are trying
to reclaim America, according to our friend
Zack Patrizio from The Daily Beast.
Their outfits or uniforms consisted of white
gators or masks, sunglasses, Blue Jackets,
khaki pants, brown boots, hats, shin guards
and masks.
They also had American flags, plastic shields.
That looked really like toys, if you look
at the pictures and snare drums as well.
Now how did police react?
Well, police shadowed the group.
Apparently, to prevent conflicts from starting,
and there are some who were upset that the
police seem to, in this case, be protecting
the protesters, whereas in left leaning protests,
they the claim is are more antagonistic to
the protesters and are instead protecting
counter-protesters.
Now, I think the reality is more complicated
than that.
And there is much more that could be said
about that.
But the funniest part was the completely abortive
climax to this thing where dozens of them
got stranded there.
There were only 100 dozens ended up stranded
because they rented U-Haul trucks to get themselves
to the rally.
And one of the big trucks couldn't fit all
of them.
So they waited for hours as the truck made
multiple trips.
I genuinely have been unable to find answers
to some basic questions about this rally.
Did they have a permit?
As many of you know, one of the it's sort
of like the
Speaker 2: equivalent of resisting arrest
Speaker 1: for rallies.
You know, we've talked before how when police
decide.
They want to make trouble for a particular
individual or a particular group.
This very vague charge of resisting arrest
enters the picture, and it's ripe for abuse
along the same lines when it comes to rallies
or protests whose subject matter some don't
like it becomes well.
Did they have a permit for the rally?
I don't know the answer, whether they did
or did not.
Why were they allowed?
Because remember, police were shadowing them
as they were stranded because of the U-Haul
truck issue and the truck was going back and
forth stuffed with these guys.
Why were they allowed to bring masses of people
around in new halls which have no seatbelts
for each person in the back?
No padding?
It's against the law to do that as well.
Part of the story of why was this the treatment
that these individuals received, rather than
fill in the blanks with whatever example you
want from protests over the last year and
a half sort of starting with, starting with
the George Floyd protests in the summer of
2020.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
And remember that we've got on December 14th
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern Time, we will be doing
the next David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall.
It'll be streaming live on the Pacman Live
YouTube channel.
That's the second channel, not the one that
these clips are on.
It's on the second channel and it'll be next.
Next.
What is a Tuesday?
Yeah, next Tuesday, Tuesday, December 14th
6:00 p.m. Eastern on the Pacman Live Channel.
The David Pakman Show is made possible primarily
by members who sign up on our website.
Join Packman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members.
If you like the free show.
You'll probably like the extra show.
You can also get commercial free audio and
video streams of the show.
And it really is not expensive, and if the
normal prices strike you as high, which they
shouldn't, but if they did, you can use the
coupon code better.
Twenty one to get a huge discount off of the
membership of your choice at joint Packman
dot com.